Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this series, we talk a lot about different
AI algorithms that solve a variety of super
difficult tasks.
These are typically tested within a software
environment in the form of a simulation program.
However, this often leaves the question open
whether these algorithms would really work
in real world environments.
So what about that?
This work from OpenAI goes by the name domain
randomization, and is about training an AI
on relatively crude computer simulations in
a way that can be transferred to the real
world.
The problem used to demonstrate this was localizing
and grasping objects.
Note that this algorithm has never seen any
real images and was trained using simulated
data.
It only played a computer game, if you will.
Now, the question we immediately think about
is what the term domain randomization has
to do with transferring simulation knowledge
into reality?
The key observation is that using simulated
training data is okay, but we have to make
sure that the AI is exposed to a diverse enough
set of circumstances to obtain knowledge that
generalizes properly, hence the term domain
randomization.
In these experiments, the following parameters
were heavily randomized:
number of shapes and distractor objects on
the table, positions and textures on the objects,
table and the environment, number of lights,
material properties, and the algorithm was
even exposed to some random noise as well
in the images.
And it turns out that if we do this properly,
leaning on the knowledge of only a few thousand
images, when the algorithm is uploaded to
a real robot arm, it becomes capable of grasping
the correct prescribed objects.
In this case, the objective was, spam detection.
Very amusing.
I think the very interesting part is that
it is not even using photorealistic rendering
and light simulations - these programs are
able to create high quality images that resemble
the real world around us, and it is mostly
clear that those would be useful to train
such an algorithm.
However, this only uses extremely crude data
and the knowledge of the AI still generalizes
to the real world.
How about that!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!